guardano tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio incredibile
stratosferico can't wait to see this
video è già preso la marcia
effettivamente anche tt ha passato dei
momenti di me alla sua vita ci può stare
[Musica]
ragazzi diventato palesemente uno stand
i giudici
the others qing qiu mano io non continuo
a non capire perché c'è tutta questa
incazzatura che le pubblicità del rame
piccante perché era mense piccante uno
deve essere perché ram n tipica chi da
fastidio qui ti incazzi allora perché lo
mangi change my mind il piccante è una
mera come l'acqua frizzante fissa da
fastidio non di seta frizza che fastidio
sto bevendo l'acqua non voglio che mi
dia fastidio la gola bevo normale voglio
mangiare non poi un esercito di pompieri
che mi spruzzato nella gola perché sto
morendo no voglio sentire il cibo quindi
e piccante una mera e titti lo ha capito
guardarmelo ha capito si vede quale
conterrà depresso varda si vedeva
[Musica]
l'altro questo non è il motivo della
sedia di più di paio mi sbaglio io non
so lamiera non copiato 12 la coca cola
non ha mai fatto un drink che io sappia
te c'è solo in giappone le nascite che
la coca cola serve dopo che hai bevuto
dopo che hai mangiato piccante non ho
capito niente andò avanti di lonato
cointestato con la borsetta collo basta
basta me lo sogno anche la notte basta
piccola non ce la faccio piove del suo
gatto vi prego ragazzi basta
ponete fine la mia sofferenza santoli
dio tutto sto bordello era per un caffè
in brik quindi una merda chiamato cafone
chicca me la fanno passare sta roba
degli universal studios sul giappone
ragazzi invece passa cosa più spiega che
il muro
ce la fanno passare come se fosse la
trazione proprio del secolo il parco
divertimenti piu figo del pianeta in cui
talucci dal marzo al 100 sembravano che
tu non possa fare a meno di andarci e
forse veramente pazzesco sapete qual è
la verità è che lo è libera tutti
jumaine o libera mango parmigiano
catechisti nome si paragona kimi troppo
lei tocca molto bravo a terra se farò io
roba da bere fina finalmente roba da
bere che cacchio era nora è da una vita
che non vedevano cadaveri tranne un
secondo fa quando giochi da cani a fort
night a league of legends da tutti quei
giochini non sai giocare e la gente cosa
dice dice proprio questi casi gatti nei
tubi oddio no guardi soprattutto
rivedere o casinò ha provato mi guarda
quante più
[Musica]
no basta ballare altra volta l'hai fatto
gino che è successo ma coach ferri
beylouni bosco hanno fatto bene ferita
io l'ho detto giusto però basta a far
ballare fino sul molo basta sempre così
spuntata una che piazza gli adesivi
sulla gente
[Musica]
e addetti saputo di aree contro scusami
come che leggi ri al golden giapponese
ieri a rogoredo avanti ragazzi odio
questa partita bella ciao matteo si è
fermato addio professor si fosse fermata
sulle rotaie fettuccine no no no ma come
tubi continue ma cosa con uovo visto una
roba per con un treno fatta sembra
drammatica dal continuo di your name
fatto al live action e poi la pubblicità
e delle fettuccine lo stai calmo ciao
ciao ciao che che camomilla qua che
basta stai calmo che è successo qua che
è successo qua ma lo tengono dentro
creduta che alla fine era ragù radu
pronto in vista una mergo lauren ashley
tait lo diventa il supersonico
e io
se l'intelligenza dipendesse da quanti
chewing gum mastichi oscurata di stato
un genio ma proprio che la serie che
avrà inventato il computer
miller dai teen star motyka in gara 3
anche
poi nelle foto la final fantasy vii e
mail agenda del cinema non sono al
cinema io voglio proprio vedere questa
prima si era la bene ed era da bere
non ho capito niente era davvero pizza
hut tanto sarà davvero per questo tipo
pensate si sa che di più adesso spunta
bibita quanto era citata questa qua
contentissima proprio di aver saputo
guardare troppo ai una pizza in mano un
attimo cioè albergo pizza in mano in
siciliano vuol dire una cosa brutta non
ho nel senso di pizza sta parlando
pizarro che fa il quartetto
fraintendibile concordiamo svizzera vita
cioè una pizza verta pizza atto
[Musica]
mark martin a rudy zerbi carpi dove lo
vedo lo zio kalbe calbi volendo non cale
pizzi dovrai visto su jack sparrow
i ragazzi ma cos'è chi rahimova bel
niente da un import orniamo sulla roba
l'avere per cortesia che mi sento un
attimo a una bibita limone vorrei
tornare sul wrobel avere mi sentono di
nuovo fuori da sola conseguita schroders
l'esperto cioccolato
c'è qui top ma no cicli pozzi line è un
po vedono scorrere uscito fuori
prima 5 guariremo nel mondo
e
grazie
[Musica]
madonna poeta l'altro quanto sono poco
sembra un posto di snake versione
giapponese però non sono tanto
convincenti per questo c'è un manifesto
dietro con uno così non posso prendere
seriamente si samurai veramente da
guardia finiamo
[Musica]
ha tirato nostro ma basta le uvette
madonna quanto ci campano e basta cosa
sto vedendo cosa vedo cosa
[Musica]
nel sinistro juve con cui l'hai mai
riesco io come quel aimar e se no io io
io io io io allora come come allora
analizziamo bbb 2 kg per cortesia
analizziamo c'è qualcuno che si sta
sposando con salsa di soia e va bene
[Musica]
cos'è cos'è
cosa ho visto cosa stop e da noi e
questo è solo gli ufo come con la ma
perché lui è convintissimo lui è
veramente il più convinto del mondo sto
vedendo cos'era gli under e simulator sa
cos'è credo che ci sia talmente tanto 35
st pubblicità che penso sia l'amico è la
pubblicità del del video questa la pista
è la finale purtroppo cosa vedo
nei suoi live si segua guarda se c'è una
possibilità di mangiarlo ti assicuro che
non lo mangerò mai
signori questa è la comicità giapponesi
di giudei e stato sempre è un po come
scavare dentro se stessi questo perché
vi sia un percorso psicologico
da non sottovalutare ragazzi non vedo
l'ora di vedere il professore di soldi
per adesso concluso qua ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
a crearsi è già del tasto mi piace è
direi che noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]